you have worked with a lot of
extraordinary men i mean
money penny bond hello i know
money penny
[Applause]
how about
those extraordinary men i've been very
very lucky actually i've kissed some
amazing men
i mean it's brilliant another perk of
the job it's a real great hug isn't it
it really is there are some men you're
more excited to kiss than others i will
admit that there were lots of men i was
excited to kiss i have to admit
i love it
i mean idris elba for instance this is
amazing
[Music]
can i you're just getting everything out
of me
it's really disturbing i'm like we just
started where are we gonna go is it true
that you actually did get in a little
bit of trouble for rumoring idris elba
as the next bond i did yeah
it's a really dangerous thing when you
answer the question who's going to be
the next bond i thought i'll just offer
up a name you know i was working with it
just at the time so i said idris albert
and then the title was naomi says idris
elba to be next bond and did that went
everywhere the broccoli family like say
no they knew that i'd fallen into the
journalists traps perfect yeah okay okay
but then idris held it against me
because he was like in every interview i
have to answer questions about being the
next one so sometimes i like like weird
avant-garde questions will you play my
favorite game with me okay let's do it
okay
in honor of um your alien run-ins on
your new show the man who fell to earth
um we're gonna play the final five
number one what travel destination would
you bring an alien to here on earth um i
would take them to costa rica because
i'm obsessed with costa rica so they'd
have to see it with me all right number
two have you ever witnessed anything
extraterrestrial
i have not i have to tell you my mom and
my stepdad they go out a lot of nights
with their deck chairs and they um go to
these secret locations where they hear
that aliens have appeared and they wait
all night for them to appear were they
excited for this role for you if they
kind of love
the other world they haven't seen it yet
but they're super excited about it yeah
it's totally their kind of thing okay
number three what human trait would you
teach to an alien i think the most
important human trait is forgiveness
where can we go without forgiveness
of self as well
other people and of
um okay what is the first food that you
would introduce to an alien a green
smoothie because it's very healthy i
want them to be healthy and last a long
time and last but not least would you
ever date an alien
absolutely
[Applause]
april 24th on show time and i will say
it is a magnificent show it is really
extraordinary i think it's going to turn
heads you guys are incredible in it and
it is really well done thank you so much
thank you so much
[Music]
you